hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel wet today we are celebrating
120,000 subscribers with another QA I'm
actually going to put my glasses on so
that I can read these comments better
let's see just the evil young bill from
Instagram asks would you ever consider
doing performance capture for a game
let's say if you got an offer from an
insect big studio here I would 100% do
performance capture for a game I'd also
love to do voice acting for a game
however I will not do either of those
things while working as a journalist so
ultimately it's a breach of my ethical
code I know that other people have
different ones but I ultimately would
not be comfortable doing that right now
though I don't imagine I'll be in games
media forever so we'll see how that goes
NIC 87 what is your natural hair color
and what makes you diet so many
different colors my natural hair color
is the color you can see at the top
there but for context when it's next to
blond it makes it look a lot darker than
it actually is I'm actually going a
lighter blonde on Friday like Daenerys
white hopefully it could take like
someone wants to get that but that's
what I'm trying to do get rid of the
kind of more brassy colors that we have
going on yet the reason that I dye my
hair a lot and that is actually a reason
for this so I basically don't like my
hair when it's natural because it gets
incredibly oily I have naturally very
very oily hair bleaching my hair which
is what makes it white uh basically
means it's naturally dry uh which means
it doesn't get as oily I ultimately like
want to shave all my hair off when it's
brown because it is so annoying work
with so I go light and then I change the
colour based on it fading so the idea is
like right now my hair's really uneven
so I'm trying to get it an even color
eventually that will stop walking and
I'll have to put another color until I
kind of start over again and that's
basically how it works
Kel's show us what's your favorite bus
person shooter ever man the first one
type like what battlefield 1942 and
battlefield vietnam which I mean I
should mention I also have a really soft
spot for bad company to Rainbow Six
Vegas and Rainbow Six Vegas to a very
much up there I also think siege is a
very good first-person shooter but I
haven't put half as much time in
that of course Hey look it was less hot
on three than most people but yeah halo
one is probably one of my favorite games
full stop I feel like it's probably a
damn I'm forgetting like obviously you
guys probably already know that I loved
Wolfenstein the new order and
Wolfenstein the new Colossus so those
two all 100% up there is well I play a
fair bit of counter-strike back in the
day I don't know there's almost
definitely stuff I'm forgetting here SD
midnight said when do you think you'll
hit 1 million subscribers when you're
old and gray I would be shocked if my
channel and it hits 1 million
subscribers it is a very slow growing
channel I think I probably have like 135
at the end of this year like it would
take me I don't know someone else
through the math on that a very long
time to hit a million subscribers but
that's okay someone else can do that I
don't need that Jason G on Facebook
asked what are three games that came out
in 2017 that everyone loved that you
hated uh I don't think any games fit
that bill specifically but four games
that everyone loved that I didn't like
as much Super Mario Odyssey please don't
yell at me I think it's a good game
think it's a great game I just don't
think it's like a ten out of ten good
game alright wasn't for me personally me
number two destiny - I played a lot of
vanilla destiny and I like destiny I
just lost interest in destiny - just
didn't grab me and number one is
definitely what remains of Edith Fitch
but for a kind of different reason it's
something I didn't like
Edith Finch either it's that like I'm
shocked by the amount of people putting
it inside number one game of the year
because I just didn't really get that
game for the most part you just left me
with nothing I didn't feel anything I
didn't feel immoral I didn't feel
sadness I didn't feel emptiness it just
seemed like I was exploring and playing
these kind of cool minigames but that
was all I really took from it I just
can't figure out why people admire it so
much or you had such emotional responses
to it and that's why I would say it kind
of fits in
category my name is white one on
Instagram Aussies the IGN show still a
think it was awesome and you guys worked
on it I want more the idea was on the
other side for one season for anyone who
doesn't know this was the show that I
was hosting on Disney last year with a
few of our Chan folks I ran for three
months and that's all it was signed for
if it comes back it will absolutely not
be in the same format so effectively the
version of the IGN show you were washing
is indeed done 79 mossie said do you
have a CEO self leaving IGN and setting
up your own a game media company you
know like creating your own version of
IGN or splitting off with friends to do
a kind of funny sort of thing no Robbie
o koba on Facebook cost why do we feel
damn dog
that's deep Juan Manuel us what is in
the next goal anything beyond our
outside of IGN yeah I have no idea
I have no idea where to go from here
I let me know when you figure out what I
should do because I am currently just
completely clueless Chris whom on
Instagram said Lana can we follow you on
Xbox Live for fun you keep what yes you
can follow me on Xbox Live my gamertag
is char Lana Zod it's about the exact
same way as my YouTube URL and my
Instagram and my Twitter and my facebook
I have accounts that are completely
unrelated names on PSN on on PC just so
that people can't add me on those to
keep the private which is mostly for
work reasons the reason that my xbox is
always going to be public is that I like
achievements and was not willing to make
a second account because that would mean
splitting up my achievements so it is
all righty you guys thank you so much to
everyone who asked questions to anyone
who asked how I got my job I will leave
a link in the description below to the
video I already made about that that
explains and everything I did from stop
to finish to get my job at IGN that is
it for me today
you guys huge thanks everyone whose
names are
screen right now fun fact that everyone
on patreon gets a monthly Q&A that's
like 30 minutes long it's basically a
mini podcasts that gets pretty crazy I
answered literally every question that's
fun already I will see you guys next
time boy